[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el día de
hoy hablaremos del informe de naciones
unidas donde se evidencia violaciones de
los derechos humanos en venezuela
amparados por el gobierno de nicolás
maduro al respecto conversamos con marta
baliñas la ex presidenta de la misión de
verificación independiente de naciones
unidas para la determinación de los
hechos en venezuela quien nos habló
sobre cuáles fueron los procedimientos
que realizó la misión de verificación de
la onu para llegar a la conclusión de
que el gobierno de nicolás maduro
cometió crímenes de lesa humanidad de su
pueblo con los hijos si nuestra misión
llevó a cabo investigaciones durante los
últimos meses investigaciones detalladas
sobre casos de violaciones de derechos
humanos en venezuela en nuestro mandato
incluye cuatro tipos de violaciones de
derechos humanos que son las ejecuciones
extrajudiciales las desapariciones
forzadas
las detenciones arbitrarias y la tortura
y otros actos crueles incluyendo actos
de violencia sexual y de género nosotros
hemos hablado con diferentes fue fuentes
de información desafortunadamente no
hemos podido visitar el país y hacer
parte de las investigaciones en
venezuela porque hemos contactado el
gobierno varias veces y nunca tuvimos de
respuesta a ninguna de nuestras
comunicaciones en las cuales también
veíamos solicitamos la autorización para
visitar el país y aún así y gracias a
todos los avances tecnológicos con los
cuales podemos contar hoy en día ya
hemos podido hacer entrevistas de una
forma segura
y diremos
con
víctimas otros testigos derecho directos
de los hechos pero también es importante
decir con algunos miembros integrantes o
ex integrantes de las fuerzas que
identificamos en el informe como siendo
responsables por estas violaciones
además nos aclaró si solamente tuvieron
acceso a documentos audiovisuales o
también pudieron tener contacto con las
víctimas de estos casos de violaciones a
los derechos humanos no no nuestras
investigaciones no están solo
[Música]
basadas en el material que nos hicieron
llegar otras organizaciones sino que
nosotros mismos hemos hablado con como
he dicho con víctimas testigos directos
también con los abogados que estuvieran
involucrados y que saben qué pasó en
términos de la investigación si o no
cómo actuarán los jueces y como he dicho
también con algunos miembros de las
fuerzas de seguridad estatales y de las
de los órganos de inteligencia que
identificamos como responsables pero que
viene después de este informe puede esta
situación escalar a otras instancias
internacionales dejemos que sea va
líneas que nos expliquen
si el próximo paso es que el 23 de
septiembre vamos a estar presentando
oficialmente nuestro informe en el seno
del consejo de derechos humanos de la
onu ahí vamos a presentar detalladamente
nuestros hallazgos y nuestras
conclusiones y muy importante nuestras
recomendaciones en el informe hacemos 65
recomendaciones la gran parte de las
cuales están direccionadas al gobierno
de venezuela son recomendaciones de
medidas que creemos que el gobierno
puede y debería adoptar para garantizar
el acceso a la justicia a la
desmoralización de los autores y sobre
todo también para garantizar que estas
violaciones no vuelvan a pasar esto es
nuestro primer objetivo porque venezuela
tiene la principal de responsabilidad
bajo el derecho internacional pero
también la legislación nacional de
responsabilizar a los autores de estas
violaciones hasta aquí cinco minutos con
continuó con nosotros
[Música]